thank you very for nning so you know the
interesting part was when I was looking
at the profile of who's in the audience
I actually was in the backroom like hey
can we just do all QA because I think
the fact of the matter is a stunning
majority of the people sitting out here
could be doing what I'm doing and and
vice versa and so I think what I'll do
is I'll talk about a little bit about
where I where I see things and really
try to create a framework for maybe the
Q&A session which I think will bring
even more value
so micro reader started in a very
entrepreneurial way and there was no
media metrics there was no you know
awards
there was no proxy other than did the
marketing I did sell more wine for my
dad's liquor store that was the KPI and
so my my background of selling baseball
cards and then building a wine business
you know for context I built wine
library a wine business I launched in
1996 I really started running it in 1998
and in a five-year window from 98 to
2003
I built my dad's local liquor store
which had no you know I had no money we
were doing three million dollars a year
in revenue ten percent gross profit so
you have three hundred thousand dollars
before expenses my first years marketing
budget literally was fourteen thousand
dollars so this is very small business
and in 1998 to 2003 on the back of a
very young Internet and looking around
the crowd I'm sure some a good majority
of you remember that early Internet it's
nothing compared to what we're dealing
with today I was able to build that
business from a three to a sixty million
dollar business and I did it on ADD tech
and marketing I did it because Google
AdWords came out and I bought the word
wine for five cents a click before they
raised the minimum and I learned a lot
from 96 to 2004 I had an email
newsletter that had 91% open rates
because it was 1997 and nobody was doing
email marketing and my whole career has
basically been fine new frontiers be the
guy that
buys for for beachfront properties in
Malibu when nobody sees it believe in
that develop it wait and then be very
excited that people are buying seven
streets away from the beach for ten
times the price and build a framework
that is actually profitable to allow me
to hold my breath for 24 to 36 or 48
months to let the consumers catch up to
my beliefs what has been stunning to me
in the last seven years that I've now
been involved in running an agency and
working with the clients like PepsiCo
and Unilever and Toyota and Chase and
things of that nature is I didn't
realize how lucky I was as an
entrepreneur for vaynermedia I was able
to over the last five years grow us from
22 people to 800 people from 3 million
to a hundred million in revenue because
I can continue to do my model I can do
what I did this last year which is grow
Vayner from 67 to a hundred but make
less money because I'm an entrepreneur
I've no board or publicly you know
trading product that allows me to only
be stuck in 90 day or 180 day or 365 day
behavior
I believe this entire conference and
this entire space is broken not in a bad
way
broken from the way I see the world
because everything is based on
short-term behavior and everything is
based on data that isn't actually
practical to the reality of the business
how many more times are you guys gonna
go into a meeting where the math within
the ecosystem that you play looks
positive it's going well the ROAS is
amazing but the person's business is in
the tank and to me that disconnect and
the fact that our clients and the market
has to worry about 60 90 180 365 day
behavior and the fact that so many me
the first meeting I was ever in in this
industry I sat through an IAT with a
bunch of different agencies and
everybody presented and I literally
thought the business had quadrupled in
the last year and then you know I'm
pretty ATD doubt I went to the last page
of the slide and the business was down
17% yet everybody was kumbaya and around
math and metrics that had nothing to
[ __ ] do with the actual business and
so to me what I'm fascinated by is I
only do one move and I would challenge
so many of you in this room to whether
you're a hundred percent all-in on this
like I am or 19 move to 25 please if I
can bring any value in any way we need
to start having a bigger debate around a
couple of things one common sense needs
to start entering our ecosystem what is
fundamentally different in this
corporate America AdTech b2b you know
environment that I now find myself in
unlike the entrepreneurial Silicon
Valley world I came from like the common
sense fact there seems to be zero the
behaviors so predicated on what's in the
best interest of the person at that
moment working within that machine
whether in the client side or the sales
person the amount of people that sit in
this room and actually deep down you
know deep down lie-detector your
children's health on the line don't
believe in what they're selling is
stunning and to me that's fascinating
that's just an interesting debate it
also speaks to something that everybody
should be paying attention to which is
we are going to a very interesting
channel conflict decade or two that's
emerging so much is about to go DT see
so many of the clients that we trade on
are about to go direct to consumer over
the next 20 years how many people here
real quick so I can figure out where I
want to take this talk how many people
here are retiring in the next ten years
and I don't mean you're gonna crush it
and sell your company and buy a boat I
mean you're [ __ ] old and you're
finished ten years raise your hand
that's what I thought looks like it's
zero I mean where do you think the
world's gonna be in ten years and so we
need to start caring about the consumer
a lot more my biggest problem with the
way I have defined historically
programmatic or things of that nature is
I lived in 1997 internet where I was
getting in certain websites 11% click
through on banner ads right you know
living in a world where a lot of people
a lot of people think I'm a digital list
and I don't like traditional media yes I
do not like a television commercial
I think it's overpriced for the
attention that I date trade every day
but I equally don't like a banner ad at
all I just don't believe common sense
why's that anybody actually is consuming
that product and by the way the things I
love in stream Facebook or Instagram
that's gonna go away too because this is
one big game of cat and mouse right
email work cuz nobody was doing it I got
90 percent open rates Here I am 15 years
later and I've 31 percent open rates and
that's pretty darn good and and so this
is what's always gonna happen and so I
think in general what's fascinating to
me is what's gonna play out the next
year that if you're a practitioner that
if you don't actually just read
headlines in the 14 magazines and
websites we all read that if you really
had to sell to survive you would realize
that the most under priced ad product in
the world right now is Facebook
advertising that if you had to sell
something to stay alive to feed your
children you would put your money there
if you were a full-time practitioner
across all the options Google search is
incredible and I love it but when you
start understanding the difference
between sales and marketing and start
understanding that Facebook is the first
platform that's come along that can do
both it's quite impressive when you then
say the next thing that you would look
at most likely is influencers on
Instagram and getting them to give you
product placement or shout out if you
actually trade it on everything if you
actually spent money on everything these
debates matter because what happens is
you start realizing that if you reverse
engineer the consumers actual attention
then you have a much better chance of
succeeding and so I sit in rooms every
single day if I was willing to pander
and if I had a different mission at hand
like build the biggest agency I could
and sell it we would be doing a lot more
revenue because it's very easy to sell
to the market what they actually want to
buy versus what I actually want to sell
them which is the thing that I think
most sells product and so I
as a macro and I'm going very high level
I would just like more debate about math
being only one part of the equation and
I'm just stunned by the enormous amount
of time we're spending and just to
remind every marketer in this room if
math was what marketing is this would
have been figured out a long time ago a
long long time ago and so I'm stunned by
the fact that everybody throws around
metrics at how good your products
working and we don't deploy the part
that matters the most which is was it
actually consumed I understand that you
threw it in front of some screen that I
potentially saw it but was it consumed
and and that plays in traditional chants
I'll tell you as a weird side note the
number one rabbit hole I'm in right now
is live read radio in during drive time
radio to meet as an under priced asset
as those prices continue go down because
people think it's dead they're actually
being consumed because you want to talk
about real native advertising the jockey
reading while you're listening to the
station so for me I have this funny very
unemotional thing right I even the thing
I'm most excited about I mean in a weird
way even though I trade on Facebook and
Instagram and snapchat and things that
nature I'm not hurt even though I wrote
a five million dollar check into
snapchat that snapchat is declining a
little bit because of feature changes on
an Instagram world it's just the market
the market is the market is the market
where I think a lot of people here as
they come as as Vayner has now become a
bigger media spender as we continue to
spend money in media and not just be a
creative shop I've come to meet a lot of
your companies in a lot of measure and
when walking in to our organization I've
been fascinated by the way people are
positioning the product you know one of
the biggest things I learned when I was
building Wine Library with Google and it
was the great reason I didn't build a
PMD on top of Facebook is there's nobody
here that's gonna out develop the
platforms themselves when you're
building on the mercy of these platforms
have you not seen the historical nature
of what happened with Google and Twitter
like these planned I come from that
world I promise you here's how the
founders talk at two o'clock in the
morning at
Southwest I'm gonna let all these
[ __ ] idiots build on top of my
platform I'm gonna pick the best one I'm
gonna tell them that if they don't sell
to me on a nickel on a dollar I'm gonna
buy their competitor I'm gonna have you
read the API access tournament TOS you
can't do anything you're doing you know
they're letting you do it in their
vested interest and so I think there's a
lot of interesting macro trends that are
going on that you know when I say those
things I'm watching a lot of smart
people kind of shake their head have
that nod like you know and I get that
and so I ask and implore this room to do
a couple of things number one the only
thing I do for a living is try to
reverse engineer what brings value to a
customer and by nature advertising does
not do that in a world where it has been
proven my great angel investing mistake
so far is that I passed on uber at four
million dollar valuation twice right
left a whole lot of money on the table I
invested in a little bit later so
hopefully I'll do okay but it was when I
realized that uber wasn't a
transportation company uber was selling
time is why I made the bet right now if
you look at your behavior nothing is
more important besides time time has
become the emerging thing outside of
health and well-being of your family and
money time has become the newest and
emerging and has the most momentum of
value to all of us watch this how many
people in this room by show of hands now
get angry when somebody calls them raise
your hand raise your hand hi hi I want
everybody see this higher you guys are
half-assing it look at this these are
human beings
thank you that are upset that another
human being called them because they
subconsciously understand that we now
live in a technology world where you are
stealing my why are you bothering me why
don't you hit me up on text maybe email
and I'll get back to you on my time
don't bother me you don't know what I'm
doing right now
like they ring like mom what the [ __ ]
are you doing text me you know like that
that's where we're at so if you were
actually upset more than 70% of this
room upset that somebody calls you
which is very easy for you to get away
from you just silenced and put it down
and these are most likely either people
you love like or solidly no you're
telling me that we as human beings are
excited to go to espn.com and have a
piece-of-shit banner ad pop up that we
can't get away from and now we're mobile
doubt right and I don't know if you guys
have been paying attention but those
little X's or smaller [ __ ] and so when
you go to click it you're actually
clicking into the ad and so back in
nerds Ville math land everyone's like oh
[ __ ] two point three percent
click-through ratio yeah meanwhile that
consumer hates your brand because that
brand stole their time and so we trade
in this collective on math and we don't
deploy any common sense and really what
really pisses me off
we actually don't give a [ __ ] if the
stuff is selling or not and you know
what's even scarier I actually don't
really blame you because it's not your
business you should worry about your
business the brand manager and CEO most
don't actually give a [ __ ] and that's
the punch line the punch line is does
your product or service work to
somebody's in a position where their
life depends on selling stuff because of
your technology not their job
how many brand managers CMOS chief media
officers tell me to my face to my face
that the decisions they're making have
far more to do with how they're scored
internally on their mmm or whatever else
not what they actually believe is in the
best interest of their business that is
not the world I come from that's not the
world that my family immigrated to this
country that could live on there was
none of that and that's the great
stunning intriguing thing for me in this
marketplace and so to me that's what I
combat everybody thinks I'm loud or a
futurist or irreverent or this that I
think I'm practical as [ __ ] I think I'm
completely grounded in one thing does
this communication create the donation
to the nonprofit to mean to buy this
sneaker does it make you do something
and I don't think the rest of the market
is trading on that and I used to be mad
I used to think I was smarter I realized
neither one of those are true
I'm just put in a position I've put
myself in a position to actually care
about that end result and many others
have to based on their situation I'm not
mad at somebody who's making six figures
has college loans and has to pay for
them or has a family to support and
internally this is how it's scored or
externally this is how it's scored I'm
not mad
but just because that's the game you're
stuck within or your clients stuck
within doesn't mean it's right and that
is the friction and I implore everybody
since you're gonna be here in ten years
in business to realize that's gonna
start shedding itself out because the
biggest brands in the world one little
fun fact 97 percent 95 to 97% of the
fortune 500 CPG brands have lost market
share last year because they're throwing
money in the garbage because you've got
four to five holding companies and I'm
not by the way I'm not mad at the
biggest media agencies in the world
they're doing what's right for them
they're publicly traded to all the way
up the ladder to the holding company
level they're gonna push the things that
they make the biggest margin on of
course programmatics exciting good solid
margin of course upfront televisions
exciting good solid margin you know it's
not really planning Facebook with 47
different cohorts and creative against
it like it's not I know it's not and by
the way I'm not mother Teresa the only
reason we're doing it is because I don't
want to build an agency I want to buy
the brands eventually and run them
through my machine and do private equity
so it's not that I'm this great you know
noble dude I'm trying to buy the [ __ ]
Jets and so I'm on my own kick butt I
know it's right because I know when I a
be test and I know when I look at it I
know that we're trading on metrics that
are not practical and so again to be on
the right side of history to have
leverage I'm I'm asking the industry to
start debating like why does it look
good and that's why I like things like
moat and their ambitions and things of
that nature like we have to get this
place like I can't wait till we all have
chips in our head or wearing virtual
reality contact lenses or whatever we're
doing where the math really plays out
did we actually consume it did we
actually give a [ __ ] I don't know we're
not in that world and most of us
probably won't see that during our
careers but that is the only place I
think about and that's why the stuff I
bet on are much more predicated on
whole lot of intuitive understanding of
a will drive the emotion of the consumer
and it's also why I completely
completely am infatuated with the
creative because once we get in front of
people
look this keynote I've got your
attention that worked that was the
framework of this but if the content
sucked I would lose so the creative is
the variable of success the problem is
that has its own major issues because
the majority of creative is made for the
sake of that agency getting new
employees or new clients right and so we
have a very intriguing very intriguing
world that I've found myself in in the
last half decade I'm enjoying it I love
the people in it I just think that we
have to have more challenging
conversations because I believe that
we're not doing enough in the best
interest of our clients and they're
already starting with not caring enough
about their actual and businesses and so
we're left in a place where people are
struggling and so you know something has
to change
to do the right work and these
conversations need to happen so I'm
looking to throw them out there I know I
went a pretty high level I've got five
minutes I didn't want to answer one or
two specific questions if anybody has
any detailed questions about anything in
so short things that nature I'd love to
answer them now but thanks for listening
thank you
anybody have a question like if you have
context on some of the spiel I talked
about outside of this talk the Sherman
right over here it's coming from right
behind you what's your name hi my name's
Kevin rippy I'm with no morons tonight
hello the question is you say Facebook
is the cheapest inventory on the
internet I believe so yes by what order
of magnitude in comparison to the others
yeah I'm not sure but like is it thank
you
here's what I know that with every you
know I'm involved in a lot of
early-stage startups that need to create
transactions I have my personal brand
that tries to sell books or things of
that nature I have the wine business and
I have you know the 200 million dollars
we spent last year and watched it pretty
carefully what what I'm most fascinated
by and when I sell selling look Google
intent-based selling is incredible right
like if I'm looking to buy wine I'm
searching that's incredible what I don't
think we've understood and
we don't deploy enough about is the
collateral damage of ads as they've been
in the ecosystem for a long period of
time
Facebook has a sweet spot right now
right like what it has is in a so much
scale the biggest brands in the world
are still debating dumb [ __ ] and aren't
pouring real money in when you look at
who's getting the benefit when you look
at a company like wish the shopping app
that goes from zero to you know two
billion dollars in revenue on the back
of a hundred percent Facebook
advertising and so I look at a lot of
those proxies and so when I've a be
tested three million spend on Facebook
versus three million DM a spend on on
local commercials or when we've done
five hundred thousand on Facebook versus
five hundred thousand on Google and
things of that nature
the thing that excites me is I don't
care about just the first transaction
the thing that a lot of people like last
touch attribution do you know [ __ ] up
that is like enough like it's completely
this we've become so transactional
because math is not debatable and so we
use it as a proxy and there's a leverage
but it's not telling the full story of
what's happening and so what Facebook
does listen if you're a big brand if
your Nike face looks bad because it's
blue letters and you're losing the brand
equity that you actually trade on on in
a Google environment on Facebook you can
go dr but you can also I mean all the
upside you know we were so lucky to have
a bi as a client when Lucas and Ricardo
are actually creating an opportunity for
us to make a three-minute video when the
Cubs win the World Series
and you like TV commercials work the
problem is nobody watches those anymore
so you have to replicate it in a 20-17
environment that is Facebook's game to
win two and three and four minute videos
that actually means something to you
that don't look like a commercial like
right now at Vayner do you remember when
the Supreme Court Justice said years ago
like I can't define porn but when I see
it I know what it is fact that whole
thing that's what I'm doing at Vayner
right now zero commercials we're making
videos on Facebook to sell [ __ ] I can't
really define it for you Vayner I'm
approving every video for the next six
months and the punchline is if it feels
like a commercial to me at all it's not
getting through
show me documentaries show me scenes
from a sitcom you want to sell you know
a cocktail show me a scene from
Sex in the City in a 20-17 environment
show me something people will actually
watch because what we're doing is we're
trick like I love when people say oh
these Facebook's metrics are off I'm
like none of that [ __ ] matters I don't
give a [ __ ] if they score on
three-second fuse ten-second views
people like Google's better I'm like
Google's forcing you to watch that
before you watch what you actually want
you're not actually consuming it you're
just letting it play through say can you
watch the [ __ ] skiing video like we
are just not deploying common sense and
what blows me away is everybody in this
room as a human when you're not wearing
your job description on your nametag and
when you're a human like Saturday you
know exactly what's going on you get in
Monday and you have financial vested
interest to push a different thing and
that's where people are going into so I
don't know the full magnitude one thing
I've gotten better at is not talking
about [ __ ] I don't know what I do know
is this I'm telling you if people wanted
to build their family business they
would spend every penny that they could
on Facebook right now the great mistake
of my career is I love standing in front
of you and saying I grew my dad's
business from three to sixty million the
truth is it should have been three to
three hundred million I spent too much
money on direct mail and outdoor and
radio and banners when I had the Google
arbitrage and it was at scale I wasn't
smart enough to go pot committed I'm not
a poker player but when you have the
best [ __ ] hand you put it all in I'm
spending every [ __ ] penny that I have
full control of on Facebook and
Instagram influencers and nothing else
because the spread on the day trading
part right now is so extreme it is so
under priced and then you have people
that think that it's overpriced or you
have somebody that reads a headline that
Procter and Gamble has changed you know
like it's just sheep mentality of a
bunch of [ __ ] headline readers that
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about people have opinions on snapchat
ads in this room they've never run one
they've never looked at it they've never
seen the full funnel to did it sell
eight thousand pairs of [ __ ] sneakers
[ __ ] they don't know they don't know
what they're saying is what's in their
vested interest and for me the only
thing that I was smart about is I'm just
trying to be historically correct as
leverage to do business over the next 50
years
so I'll just say what I don't know I'm
just changed my mind every day
I mean I'll sell anything you want to
buy rocks I'll sell them
you like like I don't I don't many I
don't have any motion I don't allow try
they build the tech I didn't allow
myself to be boxed into one thing I'm
selling attention and if that's
Drivetime radio Mazel Tov if that's look
if newspapers want to sell for dollar
ads I'll buy them cuz that's the right
price you know what I mean
cool show me right here and I'll get out
of here I know oh [ __ ] I'm already
negative twenty I'll go real fast yep
mic mic huge fan talk to a lot of my
clients about day trading for attention
they come back to us and say okay well
if you're a financial services guy
you're doing predictive stuff right
ahead of day trading ahead of this ahead
of that and so we've been looking at way
to take agile iterative approaches into
predicting trending hashtags trending
keywords before it even happen so real
quick example just make it clear to
everybody so if we know Hurricane
Matthew is coming in two weeks three
weeks we buy the key word get it we
start selling duct tape and glow sticks
in water and everything else before it's
a trending thing yep how does that are
you doing stuff like that or however you
think about we're doing that around
culture so that's super practical and
smart and I would call that
transactional and I love that [ __ ] I do
it for Wine Library quite a bit I'm much
more into that culturally it's
understanding that shadowboxing is
happening it's understanding that
meditation as a consumer trend in the
way that SoulCycle and health happened
is a trend and so we're making a lot of
bets it's understanding that 14 of
Atlanta's hip-hop artists are about to
become the next Drake's and Lil Wayne's
we're doing it a little bit more
creatively and culturally it has more
upside and more downside the
transactional stuff I think is massively
interesting the problem is for everybody
in this room most of their clients don't
sell the entire funnel right when you're
CPG brand you're not selling a
direct-to-consumer you're selling it
through CBS and that's why we're at the
mercy of all these metrics the problem
is the metrics and the sales don't match
up that has to be talked about like it
has to be talked about anyway there's
other people I don't want to be rude
thank you have a great day guys
[Applause]
[Music]